all right Comic Con was this past
weekend and we have a lot to talk about
even though Marvel didn't have a very
big appearance this year they are
probably still what is being talked
about the most and that is because they
showed a crazy never-before-seen venom
trailer also if you want to be alerted
about other videos I do about what
happened this weekend at San Diego
comic-con be sure to subscribe to my
channel with notifications turned on so
this trailer was very much kept a secret
at Comic Con it is not anywhere online
right now and it is said that we'll get
it in a few weeks however we do have a
perfect description of it and that
includes venom making giant axis for his
hands and him biting off heads that's
right this movie seems like it's going
to be everything that we hope for as you
can see here a fan actually managed to
snap a picture of venom in this trailer
now the reason this trailer isn't
released to the public yet is because
the CGI and graphics aren't completely
done with it yet but as you can see
venom looks awesome here's a few
descriptions from some fans of what they
saw in the trailer one fan said venom
promptly proceeded to deliver brutal
beatdowns to a variety of villains human
and symbiote alike and closed out his
showcase by eating a guy's head clean
off his body now that's what I'm talking
about
brittle beatdowns and venom eating
people's heads off their body that's the
venom we know that's the venom that we
want to see on screen in this movie
here's an even longer and more in-depth
description from one family Eddie Brock
enters a convenience store
he knows the lady here she says he looks
like he's not feeling well
she suggested to him previously that he
meditate at home he puts on a disc in
his DVD player and while laying on the
floor meditates flashes of him running
through the woods kickin he smacks his
face on the couch he pounds pills he
looks unwell and called someone to say
he's feeling very sick he awakens
startled later he walks through an alley
and sees venom in the reflection of a
car window before being flung against a
wall RISM Ed's character rules that
human beings are disposable man and
symbiote combined is the future he tests
one on a man who has bent out of shape
violently Eddie is test later as a
salt he brutally beats men in his
apartment with Venom's help his
motorcycle is sandwich by cars but venom
holds them off venom tells Eddie his
previous life is over Eddie doesn't want
to just hurt people venom emerges and
talks to Eddie face-to-face after
Eddie's body is bent and broken
venom heals him and Stan's 10 feet tall
he holds a man up and licks his face
Ahmed's character is proud of his
creation action scenes flash but Eddie
starts to come around on the power his
gal seems concerned about that a woman
throws spikes out of her back and into
civilians at a market Venom's arms
turned into giant axes and he wipes out
a slew of enemies more action scenes
venom fights Ahmed symbiote counterpart
venom threatens to eat a man's face off
his head who is bothering the woman in
the convenience store when he asked what
the hell are you half of the face
appears in Eddie and venom say we are
venom then he eats his head Eddie
emerges and says good night to the woman
ok so that's an awesome description of
what happened in this trailer and there
are a few things to take away from it
the first thing is that this trailer
actually does confirm that venom at one
point will emerge away from Tom Hardy
and talk to him face to face
I'm so glad they're doing this I can't
express how excited I am for this
because it's something that we all just
truly want to see it's from the comics
it's gonna be nice to see it on screen
the second thing is the symbiote
actually heals Eddie and then Stan's ten
feet tall so this isn't your puny little
venom that we saw in the movies before
this is a beast just like venom is
supposed to be the next thing and this
is huge it says that venom fights on
meds symbiote counterpart there were two
symbiotes that were said to be in this
new trailer they were blue and they were
yellow the blue one has in fact been
confirmed to be riot and since the other
one is yellow we can probably assume
that it's Scream so that's huge we have
riot and scream in this new trailer
which means they're obviously in the
movie so that's just gonna be
ridiculously cool to see on screen and
then the last thing which is what I've
already said is Venom's hands turn into
axes and he just cuts people down and he
eats a person's head off so we're going
to get the real venom not a nerfed
version the real one so I'm just super
stoked about it and I
wait until we can actually see this
trailer so that's all the new
information I have for you on the new
venom trailer that was showed this past
weekend at Comic Con let me know your
thoughts below
let me know how excited you are for this
new trailer to come out and the movie to
come out this October if you enjoyed the
video give it a thumbs up and be sure to
subscribe to my channel so you can stay
up to date on everything happening with
venom Marvel DC and everything superhero
thank you all so much for watching
woof woof
[Music]
[Music]